el martes las autoridades canadienses
anunciaron dos acuerdos de compensación
para los niños indígenas arrebatados a
sus familias desde finales del siglo 19
al menos 150.000 de estos niños
indígenas fueron enviados a internados
financiados por el estado donde fueron
sometidos a todo tipo de abusos el
gobierno ha anunciado el equivalente a
31 mil millones de dólares
estadounidenses para esta compensación
la mitad para compensar a las víctimas
conocidas ya sus familias y la otra
mitad para reformar el sistema
canadiense
veces este es el mayor acuerdo de la
historia de canadá pero ninguna cantidad
de dinero puede revertir los daños
sufridos por los niños de los pueblos
originarios sin embargo las injusticias
históricas requieren reparaciones y es
por esto que tenemos un largo camino que
recorrer para abordar la pobreza en
nuestras naciones y ninguna cantidad de
dinero será nunca la adecuada y de
volver a la infancia perdida pero hoy se
trata de reconocimiento de ser visto y
escuchado
según varios estudios al menos 55 mil
niños de esa época podrían beneficiarse
de una indemnización muchos consideran
que los pueblos indígenas han sido
víctimas de un genocidio cultural en
canadá dado que uno de los objetivos de
estos crímenes racistas masivos era la
asimilación el borrado gradual de estas
culturas la decisión sobre esta
indemnización se produce casi 15 años
después de las primeras denuncias de
derechos humanos